I have a supplement called RepairBite from Apex Etergenics, very familiar with that supplement.
I don't think it could repair my herdeid stomach, but it's made ingredient is
El glutamate. You have another suggestion to maybe achieve my goal since I think you said no glutamate
for cancer patients. Yeah, you can't take that. So RepairBite, most of your gap repair supplements
on the market are going to have El glutamated. Well, why? Well, El glutamate is
is fuel for growth of epithelial cells and many cancers are epithelial in origin.
And if you take El glutamate, you are just basically throwing gasoline on a fire for cancer
so you don't want to take El glutamate in a supplement form.
Now, let's say if your cancer is stable, let's say your cancer is doing well,
if my cancer is really stable, I feel like I'm in a state of revision,
and I take a RepairBite for three weeks to help heal my gut. Well, yes, you can.
So, but if my cancer is not stable, it is growing, but I have this serious gut problem too,
then you don't want to use glutamate at all. No. So there's other supplements. I mean,
just look at the back of RepairBite. There's it's got slippery elm, it's got different things that
will help heal the gut. We use the product with cancer patient called GI soothe, which is a lossage
that you put in your mouth from the zymogen. It's a great product to help heal the gut.
But it doesn't have nearly as many things as an RepairBite does, but it might take a little longer,
but it has a decosterized licorice. It has slippery elm, it has something else that I can't take
off my head, but it does not have glutamate. So, but you may have other products in your cabinet
at home that have, that if you look at the back of RepairBite, you might have some of those
in singular products that don't have glutamated, so that's what you want to look for.